jake you've been talking a lot about
fighters not getting paid
let's just take a break from crypto for
a second what you got into the boxing
world you're [ __ ] it up people are
not happy
and then you started saying that boxers
are getting [ __ ] and
ufc fighters too yeah look i mean
at the end of the day these fighters are
getting into the ring
and risking their lives you know and
risking injury and it's one of the
hardest sports
if not the hardest sport in the world
and
you have to dedicate your life to it
more than more than any other sport i
believe
and people like dana white who own the
ufc are basically creating a monopoly
ufc fighters out of any organization out
of any league that there is
the owners take the most amount of the
cut versus the fighters
um which it's a big topic and
me and my brother are creating this
movement forward to help
fighters increase their pay because if
you're in the ufc your boss is dana
white so you can't be like
hey i don't think we're getting paid
fair hey this isn't right
because he'll just cut you and throw you
off to the side but
i'm i'm creating a voice for the
fighters and i'm creating a voice to say
[ __ ] dana white
fighters should be getting more pay and
they are the content you know without
them getting into the ring
the the ufc wouldn't have the content
that they sell
for hundreds of millions of dollars
these guys are getting paid
pennies on the dime and it's just not
fair
and so what i'm doing my movement for it
is showing these fighters you don't need
a promotion
you don't need a promoter and you don't
need to sign into these longer deals
create your own hype
use social media and there's going to be
a switch
in this narrative over the next couple
of years dana white doesn't make
good fights happen he doesn't make the
fights that the fans want to see because
he can't
pay these fighters enough or doesn't
want to pay these fighters enough jon
jones versus francis nanganu
one of the biggest fights that everyone
wants to see he won't even pay them
10 million dollars each to make the
fight happen
versus some no name or not no name but
like some smaller boxers
will get paid 20 30 million dollars for
a fight because they're in control
of their own promotions so yeah i just
feel bad for these ufc fighters they
need to get more pay
and dana wants to want to control that
and they can't say anything
they can't speak up to their boss does
dana white like you
uh no no
not at all he is uh i i think he he
hates me more than anyone in the world
right now
wow because look i'm i'm i'm trying to
take money out of his pocket give it to
the rest of the fighters um
you know i think he's a joke i think
he's a chump he started off as a cardio
kickboxing instructor
instructor and got lucky with the ufc
and now thinks he's the coolest person
on earth